walk him to this video playing a
grandmaster endless fighter again again
I have a 50% score against him
four wins four losses no draws they're
endless fighter you know
okay what is he doing twit Queen b6 yes
yeah I don't come on I don't I don't
cover those pawns let's see what happens
[Music]
whatever you do we always get an
interesting game against the guy
it's it's quite like if you play against
against the artboard against Erik LeBron
you will always get get an interesting
game but really I've got four pieces
developed and blacks got nothing
developed and I have a hard time to
believe that this should be any good
okay let's see not coach young castles
so what now Queen d3 attacking on h7 or
I can truly once also not the barrels
[Music]
came take it he takes with the jeep
phone and then let's say Knight age form
possible
maybe first that one I don't know it's
not easy to tell I don't want to fall
hopelessly behind on the clock he played
it quickly that one that's clear but for
one point he will never ever get a good
King position and I have some some
positional ideas as well Bishop f5 is
one of them Bishop f5 takes knight x
establishing a knight on f5 which would
be tried the horrible side for him and
of course there's Queen age 5 yeah I had
this one I think this was simply too
greedy what he what he played him okay
okay first to check to make sure he is
not cancelling any more and then try to
get this traded to establish this knight
on f5 just a positional idea and one
thing I can do I can just pile up on the
seven nopon i came he wants to play six
after all hmm
there's some way to pretty prevent it
okay I don't know I would be very nice
to prevent that
hmm
I don't know I don't have time to figure
it out completely the ideas takes 94
intending 96 and if either I'm just
going to return and establish this this
is eternal night on on f5 it's maybe not
the best possible way to play but it's
very tricky for black that that's clear
let's see your key one just piling up
there and I might play deform Queen f7
is not not working yet yeah it probably
wasn't the best possible way to play
okay this makes some some room for the
King and it anticipates rook g8
intending new g5 and I want to tempt him
to take to have rook c1
[Music]
yeah yes many many Center bones okay
[Music]
it's still not it's not it is completely
easy to play for blackbirds obviously
it's it's not like a half refuted to
what he did which wide really should
should have done so let's see him
getting I need to get the Queen over to
the action but how
don't see a good way to play Queen here
to be three or something yeah the night
is nice on day five but it has nowhere
to go now always it's always feeling bad
if you don't don't find the way to to
punish the other guy time warning okay
it's good she's got d3 even you know
blacks just winning now yeah I don't
know what I did wrong down really
very disappointing this was entirely
unplayable really what he did yeah I
don't know maybe maybe d5 I mean I don't
know something something else probably
[Music]
somehow is not finishing me off I mean
maybe maybe it's not enough but I don't
know check what what am i down to pawns
but it says active I mean I can play a 5
I must go kingi for first ok they didn't
didn't do anything with this check
[Music]
I'm back in the game check-check
[Music]
it's got this check I'm such such a
[ __ ]
haha how bad can you play I mean
unbelievable it was a draw again a very
simple draw at that might resigns I mean
was it was really not easy friend to
spoil it all but he did how can i play
King III unbelievable just here and
that's it
if he goes him play this one and it's
just a draw I have the Jeep on to a two
two to move amazing
sometimes do really stupid stuff with
little time on the clock and he could
win a turn every which way even this is
just a win here look here and push the
beep one at black wins but okay I mean
he should never see me 20 in this game
and I didn't I didn't manage simply I
don't know maybe it was a d5 was maybe
too fancy I mean the computer likes it
even but with Queen f3 down maybe that's
better
yeah that is better if you do test that
now that's 95 yeah this is the 94
because of yeah yeah ah so that was the
win actually this is winning what is
what is let's just you know get this
again tweener 3 then yeah yeah but what
he wants the computer wants to go here
yeah this this is this is fantastic
something like that this this is not
like it's not going to survive that an
excellent position and here yeah he's he
can hide behind he can hide behind this
big Center and he I'm just fishing
this is solid enough those pieces are
just too far away from the king
interesting
so d5 was wasn't was okay this is just
much stronger if he cannot play e6 then
this is a disaster really this is not
possible yeah yeah it is also winning
yeah come on a black I mean this is just
completely insane grabbing on b2 and not
developing anything you're playing the
Dutch defense where you Fu King side
weakened this just whatever I played is
just one possibility DD 5 is also very
strong here basically 94 coming
something like that you know yeah yeah
that that that that feels bad next game
I'm going to get him a few place let's
see like that again all right
thanks for watching